[Music]
hello everyone and welcome I'm Morris
can master Sabrina for sure and I'm here
at the sounders chess club I'm very
excited to be here and for tonight I've
prepared the theme of Duke Swank in the
endgame exclam so hopefully everybody's
going to enjoy this
can somebody describe what sucks Wang is
in general yeah so it's the type of
position where actually both players if
it is their turn right they don't have
any good moves that they can play so you
just have a typically this theme happens
in King and pawn and games but it goes
deeper than that it's not just King upon
it actually can happen in every position
and I do have an example even in a
middle game where that can happen it's
more rare because you have so many
pieces on the board that you don't think
that really can there be a focus on you
know in a middle game but actually it
can happen so but typically I think it's
the most important theme in King and
pawn and games and for the first
position I've chosen an endgame that
maybe some of you are familiar with
maybe not
but so in this position what we see is
the fact that these two kings are both
protecting and attacking upon right so
typically if any of you have studied
King and ponen games you have been
reading about the fact that these Kings
are on maybe mind squares so whoever is
good technically would have gone on that
Square first probably would lose because
then the opponent would have gone on the
other Square D the correspondent square
second and then you have to make a move
because there's no way
which you can continue protecting your
point there are no squares around where
you both attack and protect your pawn so
you know by looking at this position
you're thinking okay yes whose turn is
it I want to know now you know I should
be able to find a win but they're in
this position actually it is blacks turn
so I want you to think about it and try
to find a way through which black can
actually save the game does anyone have
any ideas so obviously you cannot move
the Kings because if for example black
would make a move like this right
white would take the pawn and if we have
an extra pawn in a king and pawn and
game we should be able to win especially
because they are pawns on the other side
of the board if of course these pawns
would not be here King and pawn versus
King it's a draw but because of these
pawns what are we going to do we're
going to push this pawn you further give
it away at some point so that our King
can get to win these pawns and then
we'll have plenty of material to win the
position with so obviously with black we
cannot make this decision of moving the
King that has been hopefully well
explained earlier yes
f6 o f6 is a possibility here with black
so what should you try to do you should
try to find a way to get rid of moves of
pawn moves on the King side but in such
a way that well white gets rid of their
moves too and you will be the last one
to get rid of a move right the problem
is if you play f6 in this position what
does y do let's try to think for white
here can I take
I can't a and then what do you do you
capture back right and then how can
white do to make sure that you get rid
of some of your moves
g4 exactly and if I play for example
have five-foot black GFI stopping black
from having moves on the age file you
have to play me five and now what does
why do age four and the problem is three
pawns versus two it is impossible for
you to win because I will never capture
I will just let it be because you have
no way of creating a passed pawn this if
I don't do anything so I'm going to keep
pushing my H pawn and and well a passed
pawn is going to happen here right g6
and then h6 so this does not quite work
for example if in this position black
plays h6 what do we do with white h4 if
black plays d5 will play h5 and black
doesn't have any moves left and if black
plays a if black plays f5 what do we do
here with white takes on g v g5 yes and
we have created our postpone once again
black cannot really do very much with
these three points versus these two so
f6 unfortunately doesn't help black to
draw this position any other ideas
yes
h5 very good this is the correct move in
the position for black to make a draw
you will see it also on the screen I
have the X clamp right so h5 so
basically it's this is in a way
counterintuitive because black actually
loses a move you typically would
consider age 6 and NH 5 right you
wouldn't want to lose a potential move
but this is the way to go here and for
example in this position if Y does not
pay attention and plays h4 in fact here
black is going to win very good and if I
take H 4 and you cannot push the chip on
and if you play a 3 then I'm going to
have the H pawn passed pawn right so you
have to be careful also with white which
moves you're going to place a cannot
play h4 so in this position in order for
white not to lose they are going to play
h3 how do we continue f5 if you play a 5
here
I'm not going to take
I'm going to play h4 and if you play g6
g3 so I think here after a 5 f6 is the
right move
also what is happening here I had for
example g5 what is happening after g5
how does white win
not a four
No
g3 right g3 because you want to maintain
moves with white you don't want to get
rid of them you want to make sure you
have a move on your opponent makes one
so because we are only talking about
pawn moves here in this position you
want to make sure when black pushes this
oopsie
just to h4 then you can play g4 and in
case black pushes g4 then you can play
h4 and basically stop any any move that
black has with the pawns then they will
have to move their King and if they do
so we already discussed that so why is
f6 so after h3 why is f6 better than f5
what do you guys think
because what
so what what moved us white playing here
for example let's say I still play g3
right that was the idea
can i play g3 is this a good move for
white now you have an extra move and if
I play h4 oopsie I will end up losing so
I need to be careful with white as well
right we are we're dealing here with the
position of mutual
zooks funk basically so both colors
really try their best to keep enough
moves on the board okay so if I take
here is this a correct move for white
you already have the hint so two
question marks pon takes and now what
does y do if I play after Ino h4 but
age three f3 I can take yeah and then
you prove if you push a four I push a
five and if you push you forty five you
have here g3 g4 or h4 but with both with
all of these three moves you're actually
you know block eight in your position
because after h4 I have to be a little
bit careful of course because g4 is a
threat so I'm going to play a five just
to make sure that's not going to happen
and now black is is going to be the one
winning so in this position after f6 we
need to find a good move for white
keeping in mind that black is trying to
trick white they played f6 but now they
still have the option of pushing the
pawn to f5 to have an extra move so in
this position white has to play h4
obviously I cannot push the Jeep on so
here I need to wait can i push a5 here
how does white win after a five
I think
and can i play for example f4
which book did you say very good g6 f5
capture with something f4 and now what
is happening here
white spawn the rank of white spawn is
it's better than blacks so by the time
you go grab that pawn I'll be winning
tricky right sometimes it seems like you
have no moves but can still find some by
sacrificing material so in this position
black has a way to make a draw let's
take a moment to find it F takes e5 very
good triple those pawns it's amazing
it's a little bit counterintuitive but
it's this position so what's the purpose
of this we're just going to play g4
obviously g3 we've already seen losses
to g6 right so why it has this strong
move well only move g4 and then what do
you do with black pawn takes interesting
and then then I take it the fact that
you have this triple pawns is not really
helping you very much right I mean it
would be great if somehow you could
capture this pawn in e3 but doesn't
quite work so here you have to find
another good move for black
g5 is a typical it's a typical endgame
trick but it doesn't work here and
unfortunately right because if g5 what
does why do G takes h5 and I promote
first unfortunately for you and you're
not in the box either so g6 g5 and now
how does black make a draw mean didn't
why just gain all the older tempers can
you see sex I take
he where d6 I play King b5
b6 I'm sorry King b6 okay but this is
it's pretty clear that white is winning
right we we've discussed it before I
mean White's purpose in this in this
endgame was to make sure that you move
your king right and now we're going to
push give away the C pawn and then start
grabbing the material that's left that
has been located so in this position and
in this endgame the nice idea is now
it's basically a little bit combined and
I think this is another important theme
when you feel that you are lost in an
endgame you need to find some stell
mating ideas so it's okay did you find
it or no no okay so what's the how do we
still made ourselves here with black
King d6 okay you've seen it but then
what's the point
after king takes before what do you do
here with black so we're on which square
are you going to get stalemated H no I
mean I would promote and you can go to
still to g7 if you are in h7
f-five how do you get there though it's
very hard to get to a five and even so
even if you get to have five the square
g4 will still be a square where you can
move your king
no not a 8u yes
no the thing is if you do that
King c5 right that's the opposition and
then the King enter so if you want to
try to do something so let's just make
sure that we get this one so for example
if you go there the problem is that I
entered this way so I'm not giving you
the pawn immediately I entered this way
I don't go through b6 right so for
example if you say you know what I'm
going to try in this position to go King
b7 and then when you go king b5 play
they're thinking okay if you so how do I
win here with white how is white winning
here
can you be forking b8 Kim she ate
so how is white winning triangulation
how exactly are you going
very good if I go King c7 exactly if I
go King b8 well unfortunately for you
this cannot save right c7 and if you can
try to sell meat in a 8 we are advanced
here we know we don't push c7 right we
will go this wind
grab the pawns and win so black actually
in that position still mates himself in
the middle of the board so after he
plays King the six king takes before
King C 6 C 5 and now King to d5 this is
the strong move that black plays in the
position and now if you play King b5
we've got the draw in the middle of the
board I mean it's rare that you see this
kind of a stalemate but cannot move
anywhere and that's why it was so
important to play f6 and not f5 because
you have created for yourself this tell
mating idea if your pawn was in f5 so
this point would have been in f5 and
then they would have been a white pawn
on e5 of course you could have captured
it but this way you've set the ground in
such a way that black cannot go on any
of these squares and now it is a drop so
and if you give the C pawn I think we
should be able to make a draw here with
leg right you still have no entrance you
plankings before we just stay here and
you know you gotta be careful if you try
to circle around maybe I'll get to your
points first so white cannot do this
they have to play king b5 and this is
how I was drawing so you know I really
like this position I forgot where I saw
it exactly either in forest keys and
game manual or in some place he has
written for for a lot of websites he was
this is a very nice calculation and game
where basically really you have this
Zuke's one pattern but
both players really need to find the
best moves to save themselves so I think
here there's kind of a lot of
calculation when you have a Suk's one
position you really need to to base
yourself yes because if if you mess up
something I think you know before me my
fiancee grandma Sarah Sean Marathi Abadi
was the gym resident and he had some
examples on where he was explaining
Zhuge Liang but in other types of
positions and and yeah he also he also
discussed the importance of of
calculation sometimes you can make base
your decision on other things but I
think was ooks wangus is almost
impossible because if you if you miss
something it's just and there was a game
actually that I think like Wang LAN
played in the in the rapid and blitz and
the rapid and blades against the Hikaru
Nakamura and he ended up winning it but
there were some there were some examples
with with with against oops wrong ideas
and you'd only win in certain situations
so it's very important to to calculate
every move and and yeah spend some time
a lot of people say that there are
critical moments in a game and it's very
true I think as you work with the time
management you need to make sure you
leave enough time for the end games we
often forget about those and we spend a
lot of our time luckily the time control
nowadays works in our favor because it
move 40 we get that extra 30 minutes so
it should be helpful but sometimes you
know we don't have the chance so you can
try to rely on intuition but it's going
to be it's going to be it's going to be
pretty tough yes so you need to make
sure you you work with with the position
and have sufficient time to calculate
and and consider every move of your
opponent especially in component games
maybe in other end games you can
you can rely on other things but kingdom
porn and games you really need to to
focus on on calculation so this is a
game that was played some time ago but I
think it's it's pretty helpful to again
show
zooks Vung idea and in this position you
know if we evaluate it black is slightly
better I'd say a pretty big advantage
the fact that this rook is more active
black's rook is more active than the
white stroke and White's pawn structure
is also worse than blacks but I would
say that nowadays is going to it would
be very hard for a white to lose this
position in the game that was played
between [ __ ] and rubenstein why play
took c1 which is not the best move in
the position and we get another
component game that I want us to see
white thought okay in this position I
only have one weakness this point in h2
so I should have enough time to get my
King to g1 or g2 protected and things
would be going well for me
so what do you think do you think the
same game ended in a draw blacks key is
pretty quick but let's see so king of
six king d2 blood brought the king okay
so obviously I think it's we don't need
to discuss the fact that white would be
too slow if they try to go grab that
pawn compared to black should we go on
the line or everybody agrees that that
is going to be devastating for poor
white so let's just go in the main line
King it - of course
bringing the king okay so we get this
position what is happening here how is
black going to be able to win this
of course
and then what because it's you still
King goes where
yes so white has these two moves king h1
King g1 he's going to stay there he
needs to protect his pawn so why would I
show you this position where is the
zukes Bank not yet you need to create it
right you have a lot of moves that you
can make with black and and you need to
push the pawns in such a way to create
an entrance for yourself
the thing is rubbish town hasn't really
played the best move in the position b5
would have been a much a little bit more
accurate and I think in a position like
this where you have this dominance of
your king versus your opponent's king so
your king in h3 is much more active than
this king in g1 in these types of
positions you have to consider how many
moves you have how many moves your
opponent's can have and basically by
playing this move b5 it's true you're
getting rid of an extra tempo move for
yourself but you also completely stop
White's moves on the Queen side however
you couldn't you save one more for
yourself so you save this a6 for a
specific moment when it might be
necessary and the thing is white will
have to wait and then you will figure
out how you place your pawns so for
example King h1 we play g5 I mean white
really just has to stay here and black
would have simply just pushed a 545 and
now which move do you think how is White
House black going to create an entrance
for his King with which move here
which one f-4e for you think it's f4
well if you pay play f4 what if I play
your before how are you going to enter
with the King now okay I stay g4 why do
you guys think white is going to do in
this position in g1
so how are you going to win now
g3 okay let's find
can I play King h1 here ah it's no cell
mate I'm sorry what I'm talking about
yes I take I take and then f4 does it
work
yes I think it before you take a five f3
who is winning here
you're winning with black so what's
happening is black winning
in this position
I can take right
hmm
kim jiwon
I dig
if I play f3 you play g2 right
no you are much faster you're much
faster yes
there's going to be checkmate next move
yeah so if I want to do something to try
to save myself I need to play for in
this position but then take a 5 f3 and
what is happening here
and there's still one move ahead of me
and black is winning so maybe this one
is winning - I put the lyre - for hmm
the possibility of playing hg3
when
so after a five Kim Ji Won
I'm trying to think I mean why did I
make that that mistake I think I can so
we looked at this line first
h5 king h1 g4 and now I said King G 1
right so g3 and now I can take this way
context and I play now what do you want
to play void well but the thing is I
take intermediate move yeah I might I
might have made a mistake so yeah if
this move now you take
and here definitely black is not it's
not going to but here after f4 we take
intermediate so we don't have the time
so I guess this way is winning as well
the line that I had was g4 here and and
if you take I take with the pawn and
then we there's no my idea was to make
sure there was no fortress so that this
king still had an entrance but you
always have the idea of pushing the pawn
trading and then the King once the pawns
get traded the King will get to two
there but I guess that move wins as well
so but in the game for some reason he
didn't play b5 immediately he pushed
ePHI first and could have let white
either play B 5 or a 4 which would have
given would have given white a couple
more moves it's still winning but but a
little bit harder so because King h1 was
played and now b5 we basically get to
the same idea and and now you can win
multiple ways g4e 4 for example takes
and now h4 g3 this is the idea that
we've seen earlier and black is winning
so this was basically just like an
example to show the fact that you know
having a more active King and a lot more
pawn moves is certainly going to be to
be in someone's favored to win the game
let's go to another position and let's
evaluate this position what do you guys
think about this next position white is
winning why would you say white is
winning
which one a no it's not past right I
have my opponent before this one is not
past it is black to move here so which
one would you choose to play here with
black what do you think is blacks
problem or maybe they don't have any
problem
hmm
so what is White's threat let's start
that way
c4 or c3 which one you think c3 okay so
you want to create your a passed pawn
you're right and then enter with your
king
give the a pawn start grabbing your
opponent's pawns and then win basically
okay that's that makes sense
so you think black wants to make a draw
here of course interesting okay what
candidate moves do we have with black
see five and king anywhere okay but
let's try to make a move with purpose
yeah so see five is certainly a
candidate move we want to consider the
trade see if that works because right
now there's a fortress on this side of
the board there's no entrance for either
either sides
so would you certainly want to find a
way to enter with a king and also move
the king somewhere but if you do it you
probably would make some sense to bring
it you know this way right and it's very
interesting this move unfortunately does
not work for black so what does y do
which one's you for c3 do you take say
five is the move
if c3 I think
I believe we're going to lose the king
opponent much more
we only give this c-pawn when we are
ready to actually enter with the king so
we will get up on the thing is it is
much better to have a protected passed
pawn than have well it depends actually
but having a protected passed pawn is
probably the best thing in a king
opponent game because your opponent will
never be able to get it if you have a
faraway passed pawn if your opponent is
in the box of that pawn slowly they will
approach the pawn and possibly win it so
you really don't want to give these
types of positions after c5 white
captures here you take back and now
white play see three and the thing is
exactly as you said your purpose your
idea from the starting of the position
was to create you're a pawn past pawn
and this is what you're doing but what
you're doing now is you have an a passed
pawn this is the furthest away right
what does it mean furthest away - what
do you compare it why is it furthest
away its furthest away from the other
pawns there are blocks on the other side
of the board which means the opponent's
king is going to take some time to go
grab that pawn which is far away from
those and you are going to be much
closer you'll get this one and then get
the cheap one and win the endgame so
that's the problem here and in fact in
the position black should not it's not
trying to fight for a draw let's just
see so c5 is a blunder after which black
is losing we all agree on this right
King c7 is the right move swing around
and you're going to see some correspond
some zukes Fang again this is the theme
for today we're trying to figure out how
that is going to happen so for example
here we can see the candidate moves of
white right you can play c3 King D 2 and
C 4 so for example if white plays King
well let's start with c4 what do we do
if white plays d4
kimby five and then where is white going
with the king if you push your c-pawn
too far you're not going to be able to
trade it for the b-pawn and create
you're further away postponed right so
now black is actually going to enter in
c4 and win the game look at this
King c4 and now what do I do
simply take take two extra points from
the King an opponent game if for example
you take here then once again where are
you going with the king my king is going
to enter either here or whoopsie or on
the other side and then I trade the
people for the a pawn in the right
moment and I am with my king with a
black King I'm in your territory which
means once my king is in b3
no what do we do here with black King a5
not be 585 right because these two
squares are what you hear like I said
earlier corresponding squares or mind
squares it sounds kind of strange when
same mind it really refers to the idea
of mine mine and it blows basically but
you should not use those kind of words
so basically whoever goes there is going
to have some trouble so let's just go
King e5 if you're booking b3 then I go
king b5 and then I enter if you play
three I trade I'm happy with the trade
because making enters and c4 so neither
of us wants to go on that square so
you're going to try to go King b2 here
but the thing is what do you do now
you need to move the king I will get on
a three I will trade your pawn and then
right so this is kind of the only way to
go for white to protect a weakness v3o
king in one right so what how do we win
here with black no be choking be one
oopsie
who is wait I didn't calculate so you
don't take you just go back right
exactly
the king has entered on the rank of the
pawns I know this sounds a bit strange
because it doesn't always work but about
95% of the cases when in a King pawn
endgame the king of the opponent has
entered the rank of your weakness let's
just call it weakness because that's a
pawn that's not protected by anything
else then most likely is going to be one
because there's always like a letter
type of thing it can do a zigzag and and
eventually get the point even if your
King would have been here you know King
b3 King before make you move the King
and then come kimchi for you would
protect the King with King III thanking
c3 so it's like no it's not every chance
and this is like an old it's an old
older game there's another player with
that name I don't know what his first
name was pleased about Eric Hansen he
was not born yeah here's now born then
yeah so anyway so c4 okay we see that
this move doesn't quite work yeah
because we simply come and for example
we saw c5 and c6 d5 if you don't take
one of those pawns and move the King
obvious you're going to lose after the
capture of the policy for so in this
position for example let's try c3 for
for white what do we do with black
and how does why protect this pawn king
c3 and now yep and here you have it the
Sookie's one can all thirteen you lose
this pawn so you cannot go c4 you cannot
yeah so you need to give some material
here so the thing is when for example
this what do we do is black take or King
a3 which one can you three can be one
actually no no don't make this blunder
oops
whoops so you take that point King v2
and now what do you do is black see if I
were king c4 which one very important
remember if you play c5 and you trade
your pawn for this one then you will
have to deal with the fact that white
has a further away passed pawn which
means you will have to go with your king
crab the a pawn and then they will win
the game so go King c4 and the good
thing in the position is that when you
take your king is in the box of this
pawn therefore no worries
you will go grab the pawn and then you
have to protected past points with which
you're going to win the game pretty nice
right it looked like you're worse in the
endgame but no so now let's consider the
one more one more try here for white if
Y plays king to d2 the idea would be of
course to try to bring the skin here
attack your pawn and then you know play
whenever whenever necessary
a3 or C 3 or just simply when you play
king b5 to play king b3 and just have
that opposition what do we do with black
here can be six king c1 a 5-4 B 5 where
do you go
why not be five but white is not doesn't
have a night to jump here yeah you're
just going for the deep one now we don't
care about that opposition because white
is a little too late for the party and
now that pawn is going to be lost and
black is winning so you see it looks
like white is better here for some
reason I don't know why you would think
that but black is the one who is better
here because because you don't have
enough time
well because it's their move of course
and you don't have enough time to trade
the C pawn if it were your move here if
it would have been white to move of
course white could be winning but the
turn is important in c7 a for I really
let's see I don't think I need to let's
find the best move here
can i play king b6 I think I can even
take on personal like you said yeah and
my idea was to do this but but I believe
I you're right I can take on Poisson as
well and
let's see
and you place III what do I do here
which one which pond the ocean are you
sure
what is happening here you need to
calculate all that line I
why don't you what I think you can place
a five here immediately just to avoid a
lot of calculations if white takes this
is one option right
how is black winning here no King c4
then d4 and you are one one behind right
like you don't manage when I take this
pawn to take the opposition some winning
with black
if white takes here what do we do not
take and we win so that that doesn't
quite work any other questions about
this end game great now let's switch
we've done a couple of key component
games these are what you'd be familiar
with regarding this theme of Zuke's van
but now let's do something more
interesting and well it kind of involves
still a bit of King and pawn and game
but it's a rockin game so for the moment
so what how do you evaluate this
position and what would be a move that
you would play here with white so the
first thing that you need to consider is
well we have an extra pawn right so
trading the rooks does it work to enter
in a Kingdom pawn and game does rook eat
to work is it winning for white
why is the king opponent game not not
won by white well you need to calculate
it rookie to King D 5 can you - King C 4
is that how you're thinking about it is
that what Black is going to play no
here's what's happening so rookie -
oopsie - yeah luckily it's not it's not
a bullet or something I would have lost
King F tricking the five King III what
you play here is black
make the right choice because you can
lose this with black if you're not
making the right choice so what are you
candidate moves c4 King c4 and kini 5
which of those is going to let you make
a draw
everybody agrees on king e5 king c6
there was no part of the candidate Morse
knows king c6 not really because after
Seif ya after c4 your king is restricted
and then you know with the double pawn
certainly I'll win this I'll just grab
gather yes king c4 thing is if you play
c4 this would be of course another
blunder because the King enters the line
that's all you need to remember that's
the zigzag thingy so whatever happens as
you can see I grabbed the pawn and then
it's over
so King c4 that's the zigzag is very
simple like to remember it's really
kimchi for King D 2 now came back King D
3 now you play c4 because now no man I
mean you are going to repeat the
opposition to towards white so no matter
where they go you go on a place where
you take their position so let's say
they go King III go King g5 now Kenya 3
king f5 just take the opposition and
there's no move for white that they can
make they wish they didn't have the
double points maybe but or some other
point somewhere else but no this is the
Zook swung and they can't do anything
about it
King g5 in this position what do you
guys think is this correct move
see for
how are you going to enter with the king
no no no it's a draw it was not the
right thing because you want to win with
white I'm trying to think if this is
possible to win with white you don't
have enough time you don't have enough
time if you do this you need to go b2
and to go b2 with ADF King default now
King db3 so now here black has to go
King III so that but then you don't go
and b3 you go King a3 and yeah and now
it's nice if you do this typically you
would win but I've got an extra pawn so
I'm waiting with white right so when you
play King B - I need to try to do this
but still King b3
so wherever you go now you're going to
lose because my King gets here that's
why c4 is the only move here I'm sorry
King c4 King c4 is the only mobile this
is the only move that makes it wrong so
you need to make sure so you don't take
the rooks of the board but how do you
win this with white how can white win
this position I mean if they don't trade
the rooks you know
rook d1 and Duke is wrong right it sucks
I'm look do you want very good I don't
know I didn't put good move here I
forgot but this is the correct move in
the position because what is happening
from the start we had this opposition
and well we also had this possibility of
check and winning the rook so basically
if you make this move you're just
telling black okay make a move if you
move your king here obviously you're
going to lose some material thank you so
much if he pushes the pawn what is
happening rook e1 no now you go in the
King important game because you do this
and now King King g5 and taking the
opposition then you get to win this pawn
because he bloke hated it a little bit
too early right
like opposition where do you move
right and white is winning so you really
need to you really need to to pay
attention here you cannot push the pawn
so the only move Black has one move only
that he can play what is that move
King to III no rook e1 and you lose the
rope
ah okay so Rock d5 is one option and
then rookie six is the other one what is
happening after rook d5 how is beautiful
mate in the middle of the board right so
rookie six is really the only move the
black and play and the idea is well when
you give me this check rook e1 I have
this square left for myself so black is
thinking okay actually I'm not insuk's
gonna have this move great so now how do
we win this with white so again
well be careful now maybe I want to play
look g6 check Kat you will to be further
from your pawns and then get my rook
active we need to try to we need to try
to finish the game a little bit faster
yes so now we calculate the King and
pawn and game check but now we don't
take because if we take how is this a
draw well for example if you play c4
here you're gonna have to be careful not
to lose so we come Kinya for we have
seen this earlier right draw so in this
position it's very important for wife to
make this much c4 because now if the
pawn is here white is going to be able
to go grab it and the fact that he has
these double pawns
basically this extra move that's very
important to give the move to the
opponent to put your opponent in zooks
long this is the reason why white wins
after king f4 King f6 you can bring the
king one more time and now exactly and
white is winning because now there's
going to be an entrance either there or
if you move the King here you can get 5
the King has arrived on the rank of the
pawn so now we're going to win it very
simple just approach last one last
position is not it's not very it's a
it's a study so you're going to like it
it's a study by a very good friend of
myself and my my fiance so it kind of
shows how stalemate basically works and
it's Johanna an effect effects position
he's a grandmaster in composition so
basically what he does is he composes
positions is just empty board thinks of
an idea and basically just puts the
board in such a way it puts the pieces
on the board in such a way that they
create
you know various patterns and you know I
really enjoy solving studies and I think
this is beautiful because it shows how
you can you can save yourself in a
position where people might think you're
losing so in this position white has a
night versus a rock right so the only
end of course to pawns versus one this
is a draw
yes and so basically what is happening
is with white what do you want to do to
make a draw night King vs. drew King
right that should be a draw so you need
to find a way to trade your two pawns
versus the one in d7 but that doesn't
seem to be such an easy task because so
you have two options to trade those
pawns one of them is 98 and place is six
and the other one is 94 and places six
right so how do you choose which one do
you go for you want to trade the pawns
which one do you think it is it's the
tricky one it is the B eight one but
let's see why so before let's see why
before it's not good first so you want
to play it's losing actually yes
so before you want to play C six right
so we attack the night the thing is if
you move the night somewhere wherever
ninety five you're going to lose your
pawn because I played Roxy four and if I
grabbed this point if you don't manage
to play C six and trade it if I win this
pawn then I'll win the other one for
sure and then win the game with black so
you can try to place the six here I take
the knight what do you do now c7 and now
you want to promote right how can I stop
that with black
Roxy for and hear you play King g7 and
you are telling yourself Black is in Zuk
Zuk because the King cannot move
can black win this position well I said
maybe it is the good move so they should
give you a hint how is black not insuk's
Wang in this position how can black
actually win here no check if you give
me this check I just move my King back
somewhere not quite sure where exactly
but somewhere and then you have to go
back to stop the pawn from promoting and
then I go back look somewhere on the on
the first rank and then in order for you
to stay with the king in tzuke's Wang I
need to play King g8 do we all agree on
this so you are in zigzag and now what
check
very good king of seven and the problem
is if blacks King gets out the King will
get three six and grab the pawn
obviously you cannot promote any peace
because we are going to have a little
mate here right you have a queen but
it's not it's not the best thing that
can happen to you so if you move the
King black and of course go back rook c1
stop your pawn from promoting and now
you cannot put him in zoobank anymore
because the King comes and grabs the
pawn and black is winning so this is the
reason why going back to the position
and that's why I wanted to finish with
this one as the last one not to kind of
you know let you in the middle of things
it's 98 that works here so of course you
have the same idea if you if you if you
trade the C pawn for the deep on you
will bring very fast your night next to
your King and black will be unable to
win so here they will probably try to
find a way to attack your night and you
go c6 once again so I'm going to show
you I do this and then you know there's
no way you can stop me to bring my
knight close to my king here or f5 and
it's really quite impossible to win that
so that's why in this position black
takes the knight c7 and now rook e8 to
keep the rope to to control the right
and after King g7 unfortunately black
stage without moves is not a hundred
percent Zuka swung because he does have
two moves
Ruka eight and rook c8 to stop the pond
from promoting but the king is basically
insuk's wang cannot exit and if the skin
cannot come to f7 to grab that pawn this
rook will not be able to get any times
you move it you're lose after c8 Queen
so you know after rook c8 white plays
King g8 and simply makes these two moves
and the position is a mutual kind of
Duke's one so you repeat here black
repeats there and as you can see you
know this theme can be seen in a lot of
positions I have some more but I'll keep
them for for next week so
I hope you enjoyed this theme and if
ever you get to play you know some end
game where the Suzuki monkeys can happen
remember me and try to make sure you
have enough time to calculate things and
and win the game
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]